[Music]  anyone who's been watching tv today  all day has seen reporters that are out  in the field covering this storm i  thought we should take a second and  thank all those reporters who've gone  into the danger zone to report on  hurricane sandy we're talking about  people who are so brave that they're  willing to put their own lives at risk  just report  on this deadly storm here's our tribute  [Music]  nobody's on the streets because at six  o'clock eastern one hour from now they  want everybody who doesn't have a reason  to be outside uh in inside their home  a number of people haven't left that  worries them but at this point if you  haven't left don't go out  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  that reporter is going to be so mad when  he sees that yeah i think i did  what he's ever been laughing about  take a look